this is your directorial debut is that
right for that is correct okay can you
tell us about her feature film feature
films okay well something I've wanted to
do for quite a while I've been a
producer and a rife screenwriter and it
seemed like the next logical step when I
distributed a movie called out of the
blue which Dennis Hopper directed and
starred in Dennis and I got to know each
other very well and traveled around the
country and he really encouraged me to
direct and I always felt that the thing
that would be hardest for me was working
with actors and he taught me a lot about
the actors craft is very generous in
that way and then the opportunity arose
to work in theater which I had really
had no experience with i did a staged
reading of a script of mine with
elizabeth theatre company classical
theatre lab and we met and I cast
Elizabeth in one of the leads of the
stage greeting and I was invited by the
woman who was the head of the company at
the time to join the company as a
directing member even though I'd never
directed anything except the staged
reading and it was a really unique
company that invites directors in to
moderate actors doing classical work
every week so I got to see a lot of
actors working with directors and a lot
of directors working with actors more
importantly and Elizabeth and I decided
to join forces on other things including
a couple of plays that she produced and
I directed for classical theatre lab
that Elizabeth starred in oscar wilde's
a woman of no importance and a kind of
film noir version i did of an ideal
husband that got very well reviewed and
so that's how I got comfortable working
with actor
that's that was kind of that transition
for me and and if i can add in classical
theatre lab I was that tuesday night
coordinator the person who invited the
moderators and directors to come in on
tuesday so i used my tastes and who I
wanted to learn from and it was a job
was a theatre company that where we
elect our leaders and I kept getting
reelected every year so I brought in
people that I want to work with and that
John wanted to work with and you get a
real natural I think you have a real
natural affinity with actors because you
listen I think that's the most important
thing in acting and in in directing to
to listen to one another you know not
just be heard but to listen
and so I knew I wanted to direct I
didn't think radio free album lives was
necessarily going to be the first film I
directed I actually planned it as the
second film but the first film was an
adaptation of a Jim Thompson novel guy
wrote The Grifters and who wrote the
getaway which I had produced as a film
with roger donaldson and directing and
Alec Baldwin Kim Basinger and philip
seymour hoffman in the cast and you know
the producing have in the directing had
are very different and i think that one
of the things i learned as a director on
this show was to really and and of
course i was also the lead producer on
it so i had to really kind of separate
those roles i think i was saying a
little earlier that i think i wanted to
also be a great producer on the movie as
well as a great director and they're a
little bit there a little bit in
conflict the director needs to really
focus on what he's getting on the screen
and on the performances and how long it
takes and how much it costs to do it you
have to be responsible but it's not the
first priority there are no Academy
Awards for finishing your movie exactly
on time and under budget and I think I
wanted to finish exactly on time and
under budget which I did looking back on
it I think I might relax I'd relax a
little more it was off it was always a
race it wasn't is it right and it was
three our nights I mean it would be 3
a.m. and you getting up it and you mean
three hours of sleep right I met yeah 3
hours of sleep I mean you were
physically that really took its toll on
you right I was 20 years old when you
started this movie and look at me
now you have to be you have to really
get yourself in good shape making the
movie before you make the movie and then
during post you can let your everything
go to hell as i seem to have done I've
gained about 30 pounds and closed the
movie was a 24 days shoot and we used a
very high-end digital system the Thomson
Viper stream camera which david fincher
used for Benjamin Button and zodiac so
the image is really I think beautiful
image that this camera captures and it
was a real movie it wasn't a gorilla
shoot we had a really had a full
complement of cast and crew we had like
30 locations which again if you're
making a low-budget indie you don't want
to have that many locations and I think
we had over 30 speaking parts in the
movie which again is challenging for
making a movie in a really efficient
budget as a first feature but I'm very
proud of the of the work that everyone
did on the movie people deferred
salaries and we really were able to get
everything on the screen in terms of the
the modest budget that we had right what
exactly what what our budget was was all
on screen oh my the producers myself all
the others all of our salaries are
deferred of John you know you took
deferred salaries and on this movie
nobody nobody worked harder than John
and so we all took a cue from him you
know you can't John never asked anybody
to do anything or to work harder than he
was doing and that makes a difference
you know you you want to when you're the
leader you want to follow someone who's
inspiring you and who's right next to
you working and that's my approach to to
producing to you just get down there you
get your hands dirty and you do the job
you don't gripe you don't complain and
if you do you know you do we fire you
right well we want to fire those
well you know I mean you know that is
that is one of the lessons actually of
malaria is that I think that that the
morale of the of the unit has to really
be cohesive and you know I had to
replace some people in the course of the
movie and one of the things I learned
was that attitude is on an indie movie
is really all important and if you have
anyone who feels like they're doing you
a very big favor to be doing you the
movie that's not the right person to
work on an indie movie we were really
lucky that the actors we cast were all
actors who wanted to be in this movie
and even though they weren't getting big
trailers and they weren't getting all
the perks if they mile rate that they
might get going I'm sorry forget what is
this okay well that they weren't getting
all of the usual perks they were there
because they wanted to be there that the
cast was great and most of the crew to
you know if someone is doing you a favor
cut him loose cut them loose don't
hesitate